[Music]
in inrun news submitted by LG i son oh
hey that's my old phrase let's get it
big [ __ ] coin that [ __ ] and it would
actually stem from me making fun of
somebody from back at home it's time
yeah cuz he had a Madden Lisp
so I said it with the list to make fun
of them yeah and it just stuck that's
great cuz you got yo man come on let's
get it
a bystander used a sledgehammer to stop
a driver from fleeing the scene of a
wreck that's awesome where do you get a
sledgehammer just [ __ ] fart in god
damn you got to be pretty strong I swing
that thing around to the Nordic God I
don't did Thor just come down and
[ __ ] smash yeah so this happened in
Miami this SUV driver he crossed into
oncoming oncoming traffic
oh no crash into several cars and then
he try to get away and everyone I'll
show you the video yes Dom holy Oh
Nissan Murano what did he do just Chuck
that sledgehammer directly in so this
last everything hasn't happened yet is
that any qx5 is this from like his own
doing yeah
whose that's the that's the car he's
inside believe
don't drop though don't walk in front of
that car all the doors open the glass is
open jump in that [ __ ] car
no move car Larry good job pedestrians
[Music]
that's time
oh no you're not driving up you got a
block oh where did that come from it was
at the kind of bad justify:center
they're claiming oh [ __ ]
don't hit the tires full it's not
anything it very hard
we know Robert oh it's a rubber mallet
it's not a sledgehammer what's doing in
the media where's the students cracking
the glass not only hit the tires you
[ __ ] idiot
you just can't wait to riot he's got a
cop
yeah a cop did end up trying to get him
to pull over but apparently Miami has is
like no car chase rule what so that you
can just have street races and just run
away
yeah the Miami PD has a no chase policy
for a non-violent crime oh no I'm not a
violent crime yes I wonder who got that
law passed dude all the all the rich has
people in Miami yeah you could totally
take a picture of the guy you could take
a picture of the car's license plate
they got photos I like I like the old
man that's why you should always have
ninja star just thank you out of insec
you know the funny thing is the other
the other side door the window was wide
open you could climb inside I'm not
trying to climb in that car John I love
the cameraman though that's the first
like video where it's like did did it
the right way instead of this way oh
yeah yeah so shortly after heating it
far he got arrested his name is Maxwell
and he got us he was a fucked-up car 25
years old
Oh wasn't what this face like did he get
[ __ ] up so the cops did say that it
appeared that he was high on some kind
of narcotic a bad woody to the picture
for man yo bro I don't consider this
picture bro yeah this is a different
color the white balance is off man
he must have been trippin hard like he's
like everyone's like smashing and like
tell them legit thought it was a zombie
attack yeah kill the crazy it was crazy
I love a guy who's always ready to ride
he's like oh we riding I got a hammer
let's go what we hitting like with a boy
why the [ __ ] that is dark I should have
a bat or something in my car I would
thank you I used to always carry a bat
in my car I used to do yeah I have and
for some reason I would have a baseball
mitt and some balls just in case there
was questions yeah I have a knife yeah
so it's kind of like that's accessible
by either hand because my thing is if I
have my windows rolled down and people
their hands inside then I can just
beautiful technique perfect perfectly
executed headlight in my trunk so that
probably would only help if I got out
the car yeah don't you violate this
space it's like sticking a hat inside of
a dog's crate yeah you don't do that
you're gonna get bit this is hands just
filleted up beautifully out of the way
it's like salt beans yeah that's what it
reminded me of soon as it comes in
all right fine go this is the car right
now right okay bro what's up get the
[ __ ] out the car drives with the knife
in his right hand ready to go and just
constantly stabbing as I as he rotates
the wheel slices his lead caps he's
ready for how you get off the cars like
this my friend it's cuz we believe that
it could be real yes because it's only
with him it could be real a gel you up
the turd I refused a turn I can't do it
I can't do it anybody I'm not doing it
again I did a lot of he'll fool me once
shame on you
Wade you Lana he'll follow me twice that
mean the leg this maximal dude he was
charged with reckless driving leaving
the scene of an accident fleeing or
eluding police you should lose this
drivers got injured in that crash yeah
good thing is he wasn't trying to kill
people though that guy he was just
trying to get away yeah so kudos to you
he smashed hard his cars already [ __ ]
three cars do you remember that old clip
of that og like [ __ ] that would took a
[ __ ] crowbar sort of smashing
people's cars and all that's in Las
Vegas that's right by that big gift
store it was like a clip or something
like that if we got no I will I think he
was it was a part of that bump bites
video thing or whatever
I'm crazy mofo told you before yeah and
then he just started smashing windows no
is he more screaming and and scared
Elmo was 100% sure I would have ran over
his kneecaps well he was on the curb and
he walked up to that car so then you
can't really and it was that kind of
light and everyone was like yeah yeah if
I was tripping like this guy why don't
you just throw in Reverse and just hit
it
I go harder in Reverse he kept on doing
small moves he was scared it was because
he wasn't trying to kill anybody
yeah that's good that's dangerous and
the grandma you do not [ __ ] stand in
front or behind a car someone's like
that yeah sideways I saw that old guy
running in front of them all I know you
better [ __ ] come to slide on the hood
dude that's a better idea if you've ever
seen seen somebody get like hit by a car
it is pretty [ __ ] hilarious really
pretty brutal or two times I've seen it
happen well number one the guy was a
hood surfing you know were you hauling
the head in the guy and he flew off and
that was a [ __ ] call and do [ __ ] yeah
and the other time it was my friend
Michael I'm sorry do I got to tell the
story but I probably told the floor JK
news but he was basically this is before
like talking on your phone was illegal
and he literally the dude hits him he
rolls on top of the hood right off and
as a friend I could not stop laughing
because he gets up and the guy goes oh
my god are you okay I don't know but he
roll up top of the hood and he slowly
fell off and I couldn't stop laughing
and about a couple years ago I mentioned
a story to him he did not find it funny
and of course till Tuesday you put him
on blast one of my favorite videos of
all time spoke goes right the truck and
it's his big red truck and this guy is
on the hood of the truck and there's
nobody driving because he had climbed
out oh yeah so he climbs out onto the
hood of the truck semi-truck I don't
know it's like a big red like a like a
Ford f-150 yeah and he's he's on the
hood of the truck and it like my
favorite type of videos in the world are
when people go from the highest of highs
to the lowest of lows so this guy is
like on the hood of the truck and he's
like he's like and ain't nothing but AG
thing baby like nothing like this is all
right then of course his truck slowly
edges up onto the embankment hits a
[ __ ] fire hydrant like pops up
against against a utility pole and he
and he jumps off the thing in this
[ __ ] roll in the street of course and
like and like the thing goes and hits
the thing amazing goes to being like
life is beautiful to like oh my god
thirty thousand dollars of property
damage over and they uploaded still oh
yeah and then it got uploaded because
his friends watch this is gold
yeah car accidents are pretty hilarious
what happens like that in candy I mean
my favorite are the instant caramel one
like there was just one way like road
rager dude and so apparently he like
tries to pull up to the person is
recording because he's been going crazy
like crazy road rage I don't know the
current the truck just thought cuz he
hit a center divider and didn't you
could just see the video going by oh
yeah I always dream about that when
people do stupid [ __ ] no there was the
other one on the fever's is this uh this
lady's recording this dude like on a
truck Road ragin so then he's swerving
and [ __ ] and then he goes off the road
but when he goes he just like falls in
he was like catching up to that boom see
you later and it just started rolling
[Music]
you